[Applause]
[Music]
the coronavirus is all on the edge that
is precisely why on this occasion we
want to tell you how one country is
beating coronavirus well let's get
straight to the point shall we
now that SARS coronavirus to which
disease caused by it is called ko vid 19
has begun to spread widely throughout
Europe and also through North America
the sense of alarm has multiplied faster
than Krispy Kreme churns out donuts
at the time of making this video the
virus had already infected more than
120,000 people worldwide of which just
80 thousand cases were confirmed in
China however the infection hotspots are
no longer limited to Asia but they're
spread throughout the whole world
Italy Spain Iran France in the United
States just a few examples on a long
list is adding countries and hotspots by
the day in a short time those infected
in the rest of the world will far
outweigh the current confirmed cases in
China with everything going on the most
shocking and the most surprising thing
about this crisis is how it has been
handled in the different countries in
the West for example when this whole
story only affected China it was said
that we were facing a killer virus then
when cases started to be recorded in the
rest of the world it suddenly turned
into a simple flu and finally after the
number of infections spread it became a
dangerous virus again take the example
of Italy where we saw the people
developed very serious symptoms and that
many of the patients required
hospitalization and that hospitals were
beginning to collapse under the pressure
caused by the covert 19:00 disease
suddenly the danger was very tangible a
rapidly spreading virus capable of
causing serious problems for multiple
health systems and that's without
getting into the potential economic
damage overnight the threat became real
and imminence the problem is that for a
long time no action was taken Spain's a
good illustration of this as infections
we're already reaching the hundreds mass
demonstrations and political and
sporting events continued to take place
I've indicated his precepts for semester
but today he can't see what she did
[Music]
however in the case of China it was
quite the opposite the Chinese
government rapidly put into place
radical measures to curb the epidemic
they decreed a virtually absolute
isolation and Quarantine throughout who
Bay the province whose capital is Wuhan
as you all know Leon is presumed to be
the source of the epidemic while at the
time all the measures taken by the
Chinese government were labeled by many
Western media outlets as exaggerated
alarmist and even medieval however it
seems that we can already say that it
has been a success at the time of
preparing this video China is hardly
reporting any new positive cases look at
this coronavirus china says disease
curbed in Wuhan and Hubei BBC yes it
seems that China has managed to defeat
the virus but the question that many ask
themselves is at what price the Chinese
government not only confined 60 million
people to their homes under threat of
heavy fines but also stopped much of its
economy and production factories
shopping centers banks everything you
think I'm exaggerating in this case look
at the PMI index an indicator that is
based on the orders the companies placed
with suppliers and which is used to
measure the situation of economic
activity in a country figures below 50
on this index indicate recession
in the case of Chinese industry the
February PMI was thirty five point seven
a level well below fifty and for you to
get an idea of just how dire this really
was it's the lowest level ever recorded
for China since the index was created
lower even than during the lowest point
during the 2008 crisis and in the case
of services it was no better China
practically had no productivity at all
and the question that comes up is will
Western governments be willing to go
that far
look we're talking about a huge looming
crisis is there no better way to deal
with the coronavirus well right here is
where we're gonna open your eyes to
different possibilities but there isn't
one that really stands out and we think
it will surprise you take a look at this
[Music]
it's all about timing and tactics in
short there are only three ways to deal
with a coronavirus
the first start by doing nothing then
practically nothing and then end up
doing everything too late which is
basically the strategy that countries
like Spain and the United States seem to
have taken the virus that we're talking
about having to do you know a lot of
people think that goes away in April
with the heat because of all we've done
the risk to the American people remains
very low going to disappear one day it's
like a miracle it will disappear the
second possibility is what China did
lock up the population and the
entire country and the Third's try to
reach a middle ground between two
possibilities a midpoint that is
effective of course
we know that making a choice is not easy
so in this video we want to talk to you
about a country that has taken the third
path and that seems to have been
successful we're talking about South
Korea have a look at this chart
[Applause]
after reporting nearly 1,000 new
confirmed cases per day over several
days the figure soon dropped to just
over 100 with this trend we will very
soon be able to see the recovery rate
becoming greater than the new cases
which implies that the epidemic peak
that is the number of total active cases
will begin to decrease in other words at
the time of making this video everything
points to South Korea winning the war
against the corona virus that is of
course if things are still under control
you know that with these things you
always have to be very cautious because
you'll never know when a problematic new
outbreak may arise but now with all the
data at our disposal the burning
question is how has South Korea achieved
such good results in just a matter of
days South Korea is a country that is
geographically and socially very
interconnected with China for example
every day as dozens of daily flights to
and from the country where the epidemic
originated that is why it established
extraordinary measures at airports as
soon as the epidemic was confirmed the
government arranged separate boarding
gates and arrival routes for passengers
from China and immediately banned all
flights to and from Hubei Province
in addition body temperature readings
that had been done routinely we're
increased and became much more thorough
and not only that all affected public
spaces also began to be disinfected more
regularly remember all this was done
before there was a single coronavirus
case in the country just as a
precautionary measure so the big
question is if they did all of this
before anyone got sick what the hell did
they do when they detected the first
cases what strategy did the government
follow and is it a plan that other
countries could follow as well well
let's take a look
coronavirus in South Korea an arduous
battle when you already have the corona
virus in your country there is one
essential thing that you have to do as
quickly as possible
identifying the source of the infection
to achieve this a thorough investigation
into where the infected people were what
contacts they had with others and how
the first patient could have been
infected needs to be done
well in the case of South Korea the
first big outbreak was confirmed in the
city of Daegu a city about two and a
half million inhabitants in the
southeast of the country quickly in less
than two days South Korean public health
authorities had already identified
patient zero of the outbreak a female
member of a religious sect unfortunately
the woman had been in contact with at
least a thousand people at two different
religious events that's how it's
believed that the spread of the corona
virus in Daegu began so after a thorough
analysis of the background of this
positive case what do you think the next
step was well basically the government
forced the sect to hand over the full
list of its members it was vital to
isolate people who may have been
infected and to take action in at-risk
areas as soon as possible during the
early days the sects refused to
cooperate with authorities and even
instructed their members to lie it was a
race against the clock and every minute
counts it the government made an
administrative investigation and finally
got the membership list it turns out
that there were more than a hundred
thousand people on that list so the next
step there was rapidly implemented was
mass testing
the more than 100,000 members of the
sect began to be tested one by one even
if they were not presenting symptoms of
any kind you have to understand South
Korea started to run coronavirus tests
as if there was no tomorrow
they made all the laboratories available
to process the tests and introduced a
very streamlined network for testing a
very peculiar Network actually for
example a curious way of carrying out
the process was developed as drive
through centers something similar to
going to a McDonald's drive-through
except to get a corona virus test in
just over ten minutes
South Korea is using fast food style
drive throughs to test for corona virus
CBS News yep that's right and it's
pretty impressive
South Korea has set up centers where you
arrive in your own car and without even
getting out of the vehicle you get
tested for coronavirus and the results
are available within a few hours if you
are positive you are advised immediately
and put into isolation and appropriate
treatment begins this whiffed response
has a dual benefit personally it curbs
infection rates and secondly it allows
monitoring in the early stages to help
prevent symptoms escalating it seems
like a pretty great idea and it's
honestly a surprise that this hasn't
been copied by other affected countries
such as Spain or the USA in such cases
forward planning inaction as quickly as
possible is essential the fundamental
thing about such centers is that the
South Korean government understood from
the outset that the only way to win the
race against the virus was to detect
people before they could spread
infection and this is precisely why
South Korea is the country that has
carried out the most coronavirus tests
per million people take a look at this
and the truth is that it seems
completely logical that all countries of
the world take measures like this and
we're talking about epidemic risk after
all the biggest problem with coronavirus
is that it's highly contagious which can
cause the number of cases to increase
very quickly putting hospitals and
health infrastructure under severe
pressure that is precisely what is
happening right now in Italy and to
avoid getting to that points and other
of the South Korean government's
initiatives in their war against the
corona virus has been the use of mobile
apps during this epidemic crisis
coronavirus applications have become
popular in South Korea incredibly these
apps pinpoint exactly when and where
cases are confirmed and give information
such as age and gender as well as places
known to have been visited by the
patient coronavirus mobile apps are
surging in popularity in South Korea CNN
business that way just by using simple
technology on their phones Koreans can
avoid potential infection hotspots now
it's true that this can clash a little
with date protection and that opens up a
huge can of worms in cases of national
emergency should our data be available
for large-scale use should our
geolocation records be able to be shared
with these terms of applications for
example these are questions that we
leave open to you in any case what is
certain is that between preventing the
spread of infection and delivering rapid
diagnosis Korea has set a record that so
far has no competition in the world and
has curbed the mortality rate of the
virus
South Korea has tested 140,000 people
for coronavirus that could explain why
its death rate is just 0.6% far lower
than in China or the United States
Business Insider but something tells me
that many of you have got to be
wondering but Simon usually didn't do
anything else apart from that were they
really able to contain the virus with
just these few measures well the truth
is no there were many more measures and
among them perhaps the most basic one
was also the most important imagine
which one this was well listen up if in
aplia tiene pelea de empezar already
nosotros queremos que Tania Nova tener
amo mucho Messiah de algún Castle
diagnostic Odyssey Pergamos que no a
transmission local seal I see a
transmission Moya limited a new control
value of the truth his question for you
where do you think the line is between
telling the truth encouraging panic and
hiding facts or even lying to people
and careful because it's not an easy
question for a government to answer when
it comes to dealing with such a
large-scale crisis when the situation
threatens to get out of hand governments
have to choose either tell the truth
even at the risk of people panicking and
unleashing chaos or lie and obscure
reality by giving a false sense of
security
it seems that Spain chose the second
option although that's something we'll
talk about in a future video meanwhile
South Korea took a risk and chose to
tell the truth and be transparent from
the beginning the government took the
virus very seriously that may be because
not so long ago in 2015 the country was
shaken by another coronavirus strain
Middle East respiratory syndrome or MERS
MERS is much more deadly than coded 19
as it has a fatality rate of 34% that
makes it roughly 10 times more deadly
than the currently circulating
coronavirus in a way you could say that
MERS gave South Korea an advantage they
had a recent experience with an epidemic
and they learned from their mistakes and
they learned that something fundamental
in this type of situation is to be
transparent with the public and treat
people like adults tell the truth and
give clear directions
[Music]
of the nearly 8,000 cases recorded at
the time of making this video almost
five thousand eight hundreds are in day
you you know the city where it all
originated in South Korea or in other
words three weeks after the first case
was confirmed seventy five percent of
cases are still contained in the city
where the original case was located
think about that for a moment isn't that
quite a success considering that the
city not been quarantined nor transport
suspended or me anything like that
how is Korea managed to contain cases in
a single city without being heavy handed
like China was with Wuhan well there's a
lot to take in here but the moral of the
story seems to be to tell the truth
being transparent with citizens early on
made South Koreans aware of the severity
of the virus and the looming situation
and of course when you have an idea of
the dangers you're in a much better
position to react to them appropriately
to prevent the danger spreading armed
with clear information South Koreans
stopped leaving home unless it was
essential they canceled social
engagements adapted their working hours
worked from home and in some cases were
given temporary leave from their drops
the streets of South Korea is shopping
centers its parks and gardens everything
absolutely everything emptied overnight
life the joy that's often characterizes
this country suddenly seems to have been
dialed down to 25% of the normal
and the question we have to think about
is isn't it worth having a couple of
boring weeks at home if it means beating
an epidemic and sidestepping mass panic
South Korea serves as an example of both
levels both in the reaction of the
government and public health authorities
and in the reaction of the citizens who
have demonstrated a very high level of
civic responsibility now it comes to the
crunch do you think that the South
Korean model would work in your country
to combat covert 19 do you think that
your country has time to implement these
measures how do you think your friends
and family would act if that to make so
many sacrifices believe your answer in
the comments below and I really do hope
you enjoyed this video please do hit
that like button if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
also please do check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and as always thank you
for watching and if you want to learn
more about politics and hear even more
of my lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there